When you are 13
and 1/2 years old,
you need to be learning
negative numbers.
When you are 14, you need
to be learning exponents.
That's silly.
You need to be
learning exponents
once you really
understand multiplication.
And you need to be
learning negative numbers
once you really understand
the number line.
Once you get rid of the
stigma and you open it up,
and everyone's a learner
and everyone's just
on the same playing
field, it actually
is empowering for everyone.
I have a two-year-old
son named Emron,
and obviously I care about
what his academic experience is
going to look like.
And I'm hoping that
when he's five or six,
he goes to a classroom that not
only has five or six-year-olds
in it, but has kids of all
ages in that one classroom.
It's kind of a reversion back
to the one room schoolhouse.
And when he goes to that
classroom, some part
of his day-- and I'm not
talking about the whole day,
maybe 20 to 30
minutes of the day,
especially for the
core subjects--
are spent on the Khan
Academy watching videos.
And by that time, it won't just
be mathematics and science.
It will be grammar.
It'll be vocabulary.
He starts with the
most basic concepts.
He doesn't move on to
more advanced concepts
until he shows that he is
110% proficient at the more
basic ones, and then
it moves him on.
And he gets data,
and he gets feedback,
and his teachers get feedback.
And the paradigm is,
all of these students
at all different
ages, they're all
going to be working at their
own pace in every class,
in grammar, in
mathematics, in everything.
The teacher now, instead of
having to give this one size
fits all lecture to everybody,
can now look at the data,
see where every student
is, and the software
identifies who's stuck.
The teacher every now and
then, will sit next to Emron,
and help Emron as
a mentor, actually
have that human interaction.
And even better, if the
teacher isn't around,
or even if the
teacher is around,
it might be better for Emron to
be tutored by one of his peers.
Maybe another six year
old, maybe a 10-year-old
who's a little ahead
of the curve, who's
well respected as
a teacher already.
I mean, what's really
exciting about this
is an interactive experience.
I cringe at the idea
of my son in a room,
at the same rooms that I used
to sit in, sitting like this,
staring at the clock,
waiting for the bell to ring.
I don't want him to
do that for 12 years.
I want him interacting
with his peers.
I want him teaching his peers.
I want my son to be
respected in his classroom,
not because he got a
perfect on his SATs,
not because he's the
smartest kid in the class.
I want him to be
respected because he's
the best teacher in the class,
because he communicates well,
because he has
empathy for his peers,
because he's always
willing to stop
what he's doing to help
one of his friends.
I think if that happens than
I wouldn't worry too much
about what my son
does afterwards.